Joe Rogan is the largest media Outlet in
the world he's got the largest podcast
he's bigger than CNN Fox MSNBC or
anything else so now in today's day and
age if you can get Joe Rogan on the side
of one of your ideas that's pretty
powerful well Joe's been a skeptic of
Bitcoin has really been interested in it
he's had a number of people come on and
talk about it both bulls and bears over
the years but just recently Joe on a
podcast started a talk in a very
interesting way about Bitcoin it sounds
like he not only understands it but he's
now getting very excited about the
potential of what it could bring to the
world here's a clip of exactly what Joe
was saying during this recent podcast I
think of Bitcoin the same way I think
about the early internet I think they
they didn't see it coming and now it's a
viable form of currency you can actually
buy things with it and I think the
government is freaking out I think what
they're going to try to do is they tried
to they try to do some [ __ ] with the
internet during the Obama Administration
where they were going to try to censor
the internet and it fell apart because
people were Furious in the Uproar and
they thought the political repercussions
of it were not worth it like the the
juice wasn't worth the squeeze so they
backed off of it but I feel that there's
gonna come a time where some government
whether it's the United States or
another government might try it first
they're going to try to implement I know
they already do it in China but they're
trying to gonna try to implement a
digital currency a centralized digital
currency that they can control yeah
what's scary about that is they could
say Khalil you know we we've looked at
you know your behavior online and uh you
have some some marks against you yeah
and so you're not going to be able to
buy this yeah or you can only buy
staples you can't you know you're gonna
buy food and and shelter but we're not
going to allow you to travel yeah
because like that could be a great thing
no it literally limit what you spend
your money on one thousand percent what
I find so interesting about Joe's
comments isn't just that he's a bull
when it comes to bitcoin and
understanding that it's a currency that
can be used to buy goods and services
but he also under stands that the
opposite the Central Bank digital
currencies that's some nasty stuff right
there and if politicians and governments
are allowed to create the Central Bank
digital currencies they're going to be
able to use them to do all sorts of
things whether it's Financial
surveillance whether it's Financial
censorship or it's simply just
personalizing monetary policy and
inflation rates for people they don't
like that's not exactly the power that
we want to hand to politicians and
central banks and so whether you think
that Bitcoin is some great investment or
you think that it's better than your
collapsing currency or you simply think
Bitcoin is a political money and it
provides an outlet so that you won't
have to adopt those Central Bank digital
currencies Bitcoin is for everyone it's
for the people who like it and it's also
for bitcoin's enemies as well Bitcoin is
good for business it's good for
individuals it's good for corporations
it's good for financial institutions and
ultimately Bitcoin will be good for
nation states as well Joe Rogan the
largest media Outlet in the world he's
now on board he understands the value
it's just a matter of time before
everyone else joins them